Let me remind you that everything I did
so far in class came from analyzing the
loadings transformations and you guys
should be really on top of those two
marvelous equations because all the stuff
we are doing as a consequence of that,
I won't go over how we derive them
because I've done it more than once,
but I remind you that if you've got an
event that occurs at XD for one person
and to a person moving to the right
at the last city you the same event,
we'll have coordinates x prime is x minus
ut over the square root and deep prime
is t minus UX overseas
were divided by the square.
This is it. This is the key from this.
By taking differences of two events,
they can get similar equations for
coordinate differences. In other words,
they have two events are separated in
space by Delta x for one person and a
delta x prime for another person
and likewise in time. Then you get
similar formula for differences.
So differences are related the same
way that coordinators themselves are,
or I will write it any way because I will
use it sometimes one way and sometimes
the other way.
Even this one you can think of as a
formula for a difference except one of the
coordinators of the origin. This is
in general if you've got two events,
not necessarily at the origin than the
spatial separation and time separation or
connected in this fashion.
So I put this to work,
I got a lot of consequences from
that. You remember that? For example,
I said take a clock that
you're carrying with you
are,
let's take a clock that I'm carrying with
me and let's see how it looks to you.
And let's say it goes stick and
it goes stick one more time.
So for me,
the time difference between the two
texts will be let's say one second.
It's a one second clock.
The space differences zero because the
clock is not going anywhere for me.
So for you, Delta t prime is one
second divided by the square root,
which is more than one second. So you
will say, hey, in the time your clock,
take one second,
I really claimed two seconds have passed.
Therefore you will say my clocks are
running slow and it's easy to see from the
same equations that if you replace the
prime than unprimed ones simply change
your domain minus you.
Nothing changes the clock that you think
you said breast with respect to you,
we look slow to me.
Then I showed you how want when you want
to measure the length of a stick with
this traveling past you,
you get your assistance on the who are
lined up on the x axis to measure the two
ends of the rod at any particular
time they like and take the spatial
difference. That's the meaning
of the length of a moving rock.
You've got to measure both
then at the same time.
So you make sure the two measurements are
done at the same time. So Delta t zero,
the distance between them is what
I call the length of the Rod.
You are moving with the rod and as
long as you're moving with the Rod, uh,
there are,
has got two points with the separated
by the length l not and one thing occurs
at one and other things
across to the other end.
The spatial difference between them
will be simply the length of the rock in
your frame of reference.
So Elle will be l Knox Times if you
bring the squared or to the other side,
l will be l not times the square root
where the Delta t prime would be some
Delta Tau,
the rest frame divided by the square root.
Okay. Not that important. Results I
showed you was a lack of simultaneity.
It's not absolute.
So I started with unfortunate example
of twins born in Los Angeles in New York
and you guys were pointing out that no
normal woman could do that except the one
from your Mama jokes and your mama jokes.
You're mom is so big,
she can have a kid in New York
so I don't want to deal with,
so that's cosmological optics right now.
So I will say pick a better example.
Two things happen.
Something here,
something there separated by distance.
People cannot agree that
they were simultaneous.
Now you got to say very surprising.
People cannot agree on length.
The difference between two events.
For example, New York and Los Angeles,
3000 miles apart. We think you can move
in a train, you can move in a plan.
You all have to agree on the separation
but you don't that just a consequence of
now the new relativity.
In the old days before I did relativity,
I was taking just the good old x and y
coordinates and I said you can take a
point, you can assign to it
some coordinates x and y.
Then somebody comes along with the rotated
axes and no one seems to be troubled
by the fact that the same point is no
given a new set of coordinates by this new
person
are take a pair of points on this line,
but that person in the rotator system,
these events have the same white prime
coordinate because you see this is the
white prime equals zero access,
the accurate at the same white prime,
but for me they're not the same white
coordinate because that has that way
coordinate.
That's a different way quarterly,
so we fully used to the fact that having
the same x coordinate what we events is
not an absolute statement.
Depends on the frame of reference.
Having the same white
coordinators also not absolute,
but somehow in the case of time we
used to think that time differences are
absolute and spatial differences are
absolute and what we're learning is no,
they are just like the x and the y.
Okay, so I'm going to do one more thing
with the Lord in his transformation.
Just pretty interesting. Let's take
this equation for time difference.
Delta t prime is Delta t
minus you delta x or c square.
You might invite this.
So let's take two events.
First,
nothing happens then something else
happens and Delta t is the separation in
time between them.
Do you do minus d one let's say
t two minus Steven is positive.
So the p two the second event occurred
after the first event according to me.
How bout according to you?
Well Delta p prime doesn't have to have
the same sign as Delta t because you can
subtract this number.
You deltek's overseas square and
Delta x can be whatever you like
that for.
You can find that Delta
t prime could be negative
for you.
You've got to understand
that's a big deal.
Cause I say this happened first and
that happened later and you say no,
it happened the opposite way.
Now this can lead to serious
logical contradictions,
especially if even one is
the cost of even to this,
the standard example both in special
and general relativity that people talk
about.
So even one is somebody's grandmother
is born and even to that person is born.
We say birth of the kid.
Take place long after the birth
of grandmother according to me.
What if in some other point of view,
the kid does bond by the
grandmother is not yet born?
Yeah,
and somebody goes in assassinates
grandmother, this is in fact,
this is called killing the grandmother.
This words are taken
right out of textbooks.
Why this kind of violence is inflicted
on grandmothers? I don't know,
but it's a standard example. All logical
contradictions involving time travel,
half the comm have to do with
coming back and doing something.
So here's an example.
It's a grandchild is born,
grandmothers not yet born and something
has done to prevent it from being born.
Or two second after she's born,
she's hit by the Mafia.
How do you explain the grandchild
wet or the grandchild come from?
Because the cause has been eliminated.
Our event,
one I fired a bullet even to somebody is
hit and you go to frame of reference in
which the person has been hit
and I haven't fired the bullet.
So you come and you finish me off.
So nobody got this person dying.
But no apparent reason because
the cost has been eliminated,
that simply cannot happen.
I instead recognize that that is a limit
to how far he can push this community.
And he conceded that if
it can be the cost of B,
you better not find an observer for
whom they are couldn't reverse order.
Because see if the car's
occurs after the effect,
then that is some time left for
somebody to prevent the cost itself from
happening. And we have an effect
with no perceivable costs.
So we wanted to make sure the delta t
prime cannot be reversed whenever the
first event could be the
cause of the second event.
So if you go and ask this
integration you've dealt,
that is positive when we'll
delta t prime be negative,
that looks is simple Algebra.
You won this drum to beat that.
So that'll happen if you delta x,
let me put a c here.
Another see here is greater than Delta T.
Okay.
If that happens, things are
gonna happen backwards, right?
So let's modify that a little
bit by putting this c over here.
Yeah.
And rewrite it.
Finally,
as you oversee is bigger
than C Delta t over Delta x.
That's understand what
does he creation means?
This equation means is that if there were
two events separated in time by Delta
t and in space by Delta x,
I can find an observer at a certain
speed you so that you divided by c if it
exceeds this number four,
that observer,
the time order of events will be reversed.
Yup.
Hi. It's not yet clear.
Velocity is greater than C.
I depends on what's happening in the
top and bottom, so we have to ask
what does C Delta t remember don't.
That is a time between two events. See,
Delta t is what is the distance the
light poles can travel in that time.
The denominator is a spatial separation
between those two events, so he went,
one is here and even to is there.
See Delta t is how far the light signals
can travel in the time separating these
two events.
You've see Delta t looks like that.
Then there's enough time for a light
signal to go from here to here.
In that case.
See Delta t will be bigger than delta x,
but then the velocity that you want,
if your frame will be bigger than one
and that's not possible in the units of
wheat of light,
the only time you will get a sensible
value for the second frame Emily with you
oversee less than one would be if
see Delta t is less than delta x.
That means here's the first day
when he hits the second event,
I light signal [inaudible] gone from there
today in the time between the events,
so it is saying that if two events are
such that that was not enough time for
the light signal to leave the first
event and arrive in time for the second
event,
then we can actually find an observer
with the sensible velocity for whom the
order of events is reversed.
Therefore,
what did we learn from this?
We learned from this
that you should not be.
There is enough time for the light
signal to go from one event to the other
events. Then we will not play
around with the order of events,
but if there is no time,
even for light signal to go system in
fact allows you to see them in reverse
order.
But we have seen that even Twitter
constantly connected that order cannot be
reversed or should not be reversed.
So what this is saying is
it should be impossible for an
event here to affect a second event,
but using a signal faster than light.
Other words,
we are going to say that if that wasn't
enough time for a light signal to go
from this event,
that event,
then this event could not have been the
cause of that event. We will demand that
at for what the theory for it to be,
make logical senses,
no signal to travel faster than the
speed of light because if you've got a
signal that can travel faster
than the speed of light,
then the first event could
have been the concept,
the second event because you send the
signal and the signal may blow something
up. But that is not enough time for
light to get there in the same time.
But if you allowed such things,
then you will find a frame of
reference with the velocity.
Perfectly sensible in which they occur
backwards and constant effect would have
been reversed.
So the answer to the whole thing in case
you're still struggling with this issue
is the following.
What the theory of relativity demands is
that it should be impossible for events
influence other events with signals
traveling faster than light.
Once you accept that,
that is no logical contradiction in the
theory because the only time I even said
it, worst is in when there was no time
for light signal to go from here to the
there. That means there was no way
this could have been the cost of that.
For example, when I fired a
bullet, uh, the cost is that
my fighting of the bullet,
the effect is whatever it happens to
the recipient and the whole thing takes
place at the speak with the speed
of the bullet. In that case,
a c Delta t is definitely bigger than
delta x because in the time it took the
bullet to go from here to there,
the light bulbs could've.
I've also gone there and beyond.
In that case,
you'll never find an observer at a speed
less than that of light for whom they
events will appear backwards.
So the special theory of relativity,
uh,
isn't another way to ensure
that everything is consistent
is to demand that no
signal travels faster
than the speed of light.
No energy,
no signal can travel that fast.
But this leads to
something very interesting
that would be of spacetime is no modified.
You see in the old days you had a space
and hear this time and let's say zero.
Zero is where I am right now.
I am at the origin.
My clock says it,
I'm here right now.
Any dot I pick here is in my future
because tea is positive for the advantage.
They have not happened yet.
Any dot I draw here is an event in my
past because it occurred at an earlier
time.
So the Newtonian view of the world,
that is something called right now,
this horizontal line and everything
I've always called later or future.
Everything below it is called pass.
But in special relativity after you're
taking dot Cohn relativistic thing,
let's draw it here and access c Times d
so whenever you have another
event so that CT is bigger than x,
that is enough time for the light
signal to go from here to here.
That's the meaning of seeing
CTE is bigger the next.
This is the lion CT equal sex
misaligned CD bigger than x.
This is the event is in the future of
this event according to me and also
according to anybody else.
In other words,
Delta t is positive for me,
but if you go back to those,
the questions since seatbelt
that is bigger than x,
you'll never find anybody who said this
event occurred earlier than this event.
Yeah.
Another way to understand
it is if I want a cost,
that event support that as
some explosion going off there,
I send a signal that goes
and makes them happen.
That signal has to travel
slower than light to get it.
That for it could have caused the event
and therefore there's no screwing around
with the audit of that event.
That is in my future according to
me and according to all observers.
Yeah.
If you take an event here,
so this is called this whole events north
of this 45 degree line is called the
absolute future.
By absolute,
I mean future of me,
not only according to me,
but according to all observers,
every observer,
this will occur later than this.
It be later by the same number of seconds,
but it will be later.
So the Delta t between this event
and the seven is positive for me.
It'll be positive for our people. They
will all agree this occurred after this.
Therefore, the effect appeared
before the cost. I'm sorry,
the costs appeared before the effect,
and it is not really necessary that this
event be caused by this event is only
necessary that it could have been caused
by this event because not every event
in the university is caused by some other
event. It can just simply happen. Uh,
we have heard that stuff happens.
Stuff happens here with no obvious costs
as long as this in the future according
to me, by this definition it's in
the future according to all people.
So this is called the future
because you can affect it.
For example,
if I heard something terrible's going to
happen at this point I can send my guys
to go over there and do something.
They have to travel at the speed that it
is less than the speed of light so they
can affect,
these events are called the absolute past.
What that means is any event here could
have been the cost of what's happening
to me right now because from that event
a signal can be sent to arrive where I
am right now at a speed less
than the speed of light.
Yeah.
This line,
which is called the light cone is a
borderline case where you can communicate
from here to here using the light signal.
So that's also considered as future.
But what about an event here?
Suppose this distance is two
seconds times the velocity of light.
That does not happen yet.
I suppose.
I go there and opened my envelope and
it says something terrible is going to
happen at this point.
That is nothing I can do.
There's nothing I can do in the Newtonian
days. There is something you can do.
Tell someone else to really hurry up and
get there and do something well not be,
you cannot do that because for that,
someone to leave you with the instruction
to do something about this requires
that person to travel faster than
light and that's not allowed.
So even though you know things can
happen here in the future and you have
knowledge of the fact that someone's
planning to do something there,
you cannot get there.
Okay? That's a really important thing. Uh,
even for people who are
going to law school and all
of you guys are not going to
physics, but suppose you're going to law
school, you got the DNA defense, right?
My clients DNA doesn't match.
He has another defense.
If your client was accused of doing
something here and was last seen here,
you can argue that my client
was outside the light cone
that's called outside
the light cone defense.
And it's absolutely water
tight better than anything.
Cause if that event is outside
the late corner of your client,
the client cannot be held responsible
because your client will have to send a
signal passionate,
enlightened that lies on broken.
So what about the status
of an event like this?
The status of this event is I can actually
find other observers moving at speed
less than light for whom this
event occurs before this event.
Yeah,
it's the order of events can be reversed,
but it will not lead to
logical contradictions
because we know the two events
are not constantly connected.
So space and time,
it used to be divided into upper half
plane and lower half plane into the future
and past and a tiniest sliver call
present now divided into three regions.
The absolute future that you can
affect the absolute past worth,
whose whose events can affect you.
And this is not, doesn't have a name.
Okay.
If you want, you can call it the
little it, the future according to you,
but I'll find somebody to whom
that occurs before this one.
Yeah.
Okay. That's also a consequence
of the Lord in Samsung Nation.
So you can see that the equation,
so very deceptively simple in fact that
a lot easier looking than some equations
with angular momentum. Right? But the
consequences are really stupendous.
They all follow from that equation.
And of course,
if you invent a theory like this,
you got to make sure that
are no contradictions, right?
Suppose you find the theory.
Yeah,
very happy with everything the last
day of lights coming out. Right?
And somebody points out to you that
the order of events can be reversed.
Then you got agree,
you'll be in a panic.
Because how can I reverse the order of
events then? The theory is so beautiful.
Internally it says you can reverse the
order of events if they could not have
been causally connected where the causally
connected means a signal traveling at
a speed less than light, good dot have
gone from the first of the second event.
Okay.
And the theory, uh, does not allow them
to be, if a signal could have gone,
it allows them to be never reversed.
If signal could not have gone.
It does say you can find people for
whom even psycho in the reverse order.
All right,
so this is the uh,
second thing and it's called the
light corn for the following reason,
I only shown you an x coordinate,
but if you have white coordinate
coming onto the blackboard,
the surface of look like a corn,
that's why we call it the late corn.
So sitting at a point in
four dimensional space time,
there's a cone and all points in that
forward light cone or even you can effect
all points in the backward light corner
events that can come and get you right
now and the rest of the thing outside
the two cones a you cannot do anything
about,
even though you know something's going
to happen and they cannot do anything to
you,
you open an envelope and it says somebody
he had is planning to do something to
you.
You don't have to worry
because that person cannot
get you in the time available.
The fastest signal is the light signal
and that won't get there and neither will
anything else.
All right.
Now we are going to do something which
is theoretically or mathematically very
pretty so for those of you who
like a mathematical elegance,
this is certainly the best example I can
offer you because it is simple and also
rather profound but it's
completely by analogy.
The analogy is the following.
We have seen that when we rotate our
axes as have shown there that the x prime
is not the same as x related
by this formula and wipe crime.
It's also not the same as why
but related by this formula.
Yeah,
nothing is sacred coordinates
of a point or not sacred.
They are just dependent on who is looking
at them from what orientation but even
in this world we noticed that x Prime
Square plus y prime square is the same as
x squared plus y squared.
They only the length of the
point connecting the origin
to you or the distance
from the artisans and
effected by rotations.
This is called an invariant. This
doesn't depend on who is looking at it.
Everyone will agree on this,
but they won't agree on x and
they want to agree on white.
But they will agree on this.
So it's reasonable to ask.
In the relativistic case where
people cannot agree on time,
coordinate artspace coordinate maybe
the square of the time and the square of
the space will be the same for two people.
One can ask that question.
So we'll we look at that.
We'll find out that that's not the case.
The squared plus x squared is not in
variant, but even before you do that,
you should shut at the prospect of
writing something like this, right?
What's wrong with this?
Good.
Everyone's on top of the unit scam.
So we cannot add t squared x squared.
There is no way this can be anything.
So we don't have, we have to fix that.
We got to have either both coordinates
in spacetime measured with lengths or
with time.
The standard trick is to do the following.
Let's introduce uh,
an object with two components.
I'm going to call it capital x.
The first component of that
is going to be called x.
One is going to be called EC zero.
Second is going to be called x one x zero
I mean x one is just our family or x.
X zero is going to be essentially
a time but multiplied by C.
Okay.
Why do I switch from t and x two zero
and one it is just that if you want to go
back to more coordinates,
if you wanted to bring back y and z then
I just managed them for future use that
in four dimensions you really have
zero x one x two and x three that is a
shorthand for zero and what you and I
used to call the position are of the
project
you've just said in one dimension,
the vector art becomes a number x and I
want to call the number as x one because
it's the first of the three coordinates
and if you're doing super strings,
you're going to have 10
coordinates and one will be x,
not in the nine will be spatial quarters.
So we like the new medical index rather
than letters in the alphabet because you
run out of letters but you don't
run out of these subscripts.
So I'm writing it purposely in many ways
because if you ever go read something
or you're involved in a lab project or
the group is studying something you want
to read,
the paper people would refer to the
coordinates in spacetime in many ways.
Some, we'll call it a, some people
like to write the x the following way.
X One x two x three x
four and x for is Ct.
That's what you call that,
the fourth dimension.
But it's still the fourth dimension.
But you can either put it at the end
of the first family at three or at the
beginning. So it's very common
for people to use either notation.
I'm just going to call it zero.
So zero is just time, okay?
Multiplied by C so that it has units of
length and multiplying by c doesn't do
anything. Everybody agrees on what?
See. So we will all multiply our time.
Coordinate Spicy.
All right,
so let's ask the following question.
What does the Lord and his transformation
look like when a writer in terms of
these numbers?
So first take x prime is x minus ut
divided by the famous square root,
but tea is not what I want.
Cts,
what I want.
So I fudge it as follows.
I rated the x minus you oversee time CT
divided by one minus use square overseas
square.
Okay,
this I'm going to write as x is now
called [inaudible] and I'm going to
introduce a new symbol Beta here.
This guy is called zero divided
by one minus Beta square,
but Beta is universal convention for you
oversee if all velocities that measured
as a fraction of the velocity of light
than Beta is a number between zero and
one.
So the final way I want to write the Lord
and his transformation for coordinate
is that x one prime is x
one minus Beta times x zero.
You might advice squad room,
so you have to get used to this beta.
I mean you're falling nicely what
I was saying in terms of you,
but you have to get used to this beta.
We won't use it a whole lot,
but I put it here so you can recognize it.
When people refer to it in the literature.
If you go read something,
what's the transformation law for time?
Remember t prime was t
minus UX oversee square
divided by route one minus Beta Square
Betas squared is clearly what sitting
downstairs you oversee is Beta.
So what do you think we should do?
We should multiply both sides by sea
because if you multiply both sides by see
policy their policy there
and get rid of this one,
then you find x not crime is x not minus
Beta times x one over square root of
one minus Beta Square.
So let me write that here.
Don't you see the relationship with
the coordinates is nice and symmetric.
Yeah,
if you're right in
terms of excellent ante,
the coordinate transformation lies not
quite symmetric and that's because one
has units of length in one as UNICEF time.
But if you rescale your
time to try and do a lane,
then the transformational laws are very
simple than symmetric between the two
coordinates in space that are
also the other coordinates.
The y direction.
Extra prime is x two and the z
direction x to be primus. Next three.
In other words,
the lengths perpendicular to the motion
or something you can always agree on one
can talk and talk about why that is true.
Basically what we're saying is if you're
zooming along and you drew a line that
says y equal to one and odors and Leb
agreed on it, we will have to agree on it.
Even when I start moving relative to
you because you've got your own line and
there's no in your should about my life
should be about your line or below your
life.
The lanes originally agreed.
There is no reason why a Milan,
Ben Saba viewers at your lines below mine
because by symmetry there is no reason
why one should be higher than the other
and the reason this requires that the
two lines, which last forever can
be compared to anywhere you like.
I like rods which are running away from
each other and cannot be compared the
lion here,
which is why equals the three has got
to be white validity for both of us.
So the transfers coordinates
but not modified.
Okay. So that's why I don't talk about
them too much. All the interesting action,
this between any one quart in it along
with motion is taking place and time.
So now let's ask ourselves maybe uh,
x,
not prime square minus plus x one prime
square is the same as this squared plus
that way. Well, let me
just tell you that, uh,
I'm not going to try something that
I know will not work. In other words,
you might think x not prime squared
plus x one prime squared is equal to x
squared plus x one squared.
Well that just doesn't work.
Yeah,
that doesn't work because one over
the square root is not a cost data.
And Beta with the square
root is not assigned data.
You cannot make them cost and sign of
something. If you could, that would work,
but it doesn't work.
But I'll tell you what does work.
Let's take x,
not prime square minus x one prime
square the square of the time.
Coordinate minus squared of the space.
Coordin with the minus.
So let's try to do this in our head.
Was waiting this and subtracting it
from the square of this one downstairs.
I think we all agree you
get one minus Beta square
because the square root, the
square. How about upstairs?
First you got to square this
guy, this guy, we'll give you x,
not square.
Let's bait and squared x
squared minus two Beta x,
not x one
from that actual subtract the
square of x one Prime Square.
That'll give me minus x one
square minus Beta squared.
X not squared plus twice Beta x,
not x one.
It's just simple Algebra and these cross
Jerome's canceled and you notice I got
an x squared times one minus Beta squared
minus x one squared times one minus
Beta square,
right?
This Algebra I trust you guys can do at
home and the result is this going to be
x,
not squared minus x one square.
That's very nice.
It says that even though people cannot
agree on the time or space coordinator of
an event, just like saying people
cannot agree on what is x and waters,
why they can agree on
this quadratic function,
you form more to the coordinates,
but it's very different from ordinary
rotations where you take the sum of the
squares here,
you got to take the difference of the
squares and that just the way it is.
Even though time is like another
coordinator that mixes with space,
it's not quite the same.
In other words,
if I brought back the all
the transfers coordinates,
then you will find x not frame square
minus x one prime squared minus x two
prime square minus x three prime squared,
x squared minus x squared minus
x squared minus six three square.
This you can do because x one prime
individually is equal to x one,
so you can put them on both sides.
This is the actual four
dimensional results for people
who really want to leave
the x axis and move freely in space,
which you're allowed to.
This is the invariant. This is the
object that everyone agrees on.
Uh, I me once again, but
dropped this most of the time.
I'm not going to worry
about transfers coordinator.
So
this is the analog of the leg square for
vector and it's called the space time
in trouble.
Okay.
It's not the space in trouble.
It's not the time in trouble.
It's a space time interval between
the origin and the point x. T.
Yeah,
and this is denoted by the symbol
national universal formula,
but let's use square
space time separation.
Notice that even though it's called square
square, need not be always positive.
Definite
you can take to events,
but with the time coordinate is the
same at the time. Coordinate the zero.
The space coordinator is not zero,
then s squared will be negative.
Whereas the usual Pythagoras Lang square
x squared plus y squared is positive.
Definite,
always positive.
The space time interval can be
positive or negative or zero.
It's positive. If x not can beat the
sum of the squares of those guys,
there's negative.
If they can beat x,
not Anders equal to zero if x
squared equals [inaudible] squared.
Okay,
so
if you want,
if you go back to this
diagram I drew here,
this is x one plus x not equal the Ct.
Okay.
These are events for
with Esquire is positive,
these and events but
with squared is positive.
Be said even for with Esquire is negative.
These are events in with a squared is zero
Savannah but s squared is positive.
We have a name for that.
It's called a time like separation.
This is called time like separation
because the time part of the separation
squared is able to beat the
space part of the separation.
He's got more time component
then space component.
No, you can also do the following.
Let me introduce some rotation.
Now let us agree that
we will use capital x.
What is space time
which watch calling for vectors
afforded vectors. Scott,
four components and the components are
x not and since I'm tired of writing x
one x two x three I will call it art
two in the specialty of relativity,
what you do is you take the
three components of space
and add one more of time
and form a vector,
the four components.
And we will agree that the Nazi symbol
for a space time vector is a capital x.
No, I've been catalysts in my writing.
Sometimes they use small x and big expert.
You guys should be little more careful.
Big x like this,
but no subscript will stand for this.
Four numbers is afford vector.
It's affordable,
creates a vector living in space time
and when you go to another frame of
reference, the components, the photo
vector will mix with each other.
Then we are going to
define A. Dot. Product
is going to be funny. Dot. Product
is going to be called X. Dot.
X usual dot. Product was some of
the squares of the components,
but this funny dot product will be equal
to x large square minus the length of
the special parts square.
Pardon me?
This is a big x.
These are all small.
Big X is the name for the
vector of the four components.
It's the position back to it
in space time. Uh, these are,
this is the same as writing x squared
minus x one square minus x squared minus x
three square.
Suppose there are two events.
One occurs at the spacetime coordinate x.
A second event occurs at a new point I,
let me call it x Bar,
whose time coordinator as
zero bar was positioned.
Coordinate this unfortunate that
vector ours with a bar on it.
Yeah.
These are like two vectors
in the x y plane. You and I,
if you're going to literally each other
will not agree on the components of this
are the components of that,
but we will agree on X. Dot. X Prime.
In other words, x dot. X will be the
same as x prime dot. Expired praying.
What I'm saying is if you go
to moving frame of reference,
the components of the vector x
goes into X.
Prime was at x zero
prime and some art frame
and likewise the comp, the backlit
x bar as new components export,
praying which at x zero
bar praying and our bar,
right
look,
it's a story is the same like
in two dimensions. Components.
The vectors are arbitrary.
It Bailey with the frame of reference,
but the dot product of vectors is the
same no matter how you rotate your axes.
Because dark product is
length of eighth and length,
the Times cosine of the angle between
them and none of the three things changes
when you rotate your access.
Well,
this is the analog of the dot product in
spacetime because this is the guy that,
same for everybody.
You can say,
why don't you study this combination?
It's so nice. She was all pluses.
I like that. I don't study that because
that combination is not special.
If I have one value for the combination,
you will have a different value for the
combination. It does nothing privileged.
It's the one with a minus signs in it
that has a privileged role of playing the
role of the dark product.
So space time is not
Euclidean Euclidean space.
The space in which we live and distance
squared is the sum of the squares of all
the coordinates.
It's a pseudo euclidean space in
which to find the invariant link,
you've got a square,
some components,
and subtract from them the
square of some other components.
Okay. So finally,
if you would take a difference vector now,
other were take the
difference of two events,
then this patient
coordinator according to me,
the difference in space coordinate,
namely c times Delta t swear
minus delta x,
where would it be?
Seed time to Delta p Prime Square
Wayne has built, takes brains with
odd. If you like x, not
square minus x one square will be x,
not prime squared minus x one crimes
where I'm using the rotations back and
forth.
So you get used to writing the space
name coordinates in two different ways.
So it not only works for coordinates
but for coordinate differences.
You understand two events occur,
one here now in one there later.
Let's say they're separated in time by
two meters that separated in, I'm sorry,
in space by two meters and time
by 11 seconds. Uh, I'm sorry,
I didn't mean to write this.
I meant to write delta x
squared minus Delta x one
squared equal to delta x,
not frame square minus
delta x one prime suite.
So do you guys follow the
meaning of the statement some?
Most things are relative
distance between events,
relative time interval
between eventuality,
but this combination somehow is in
billion. Everybody agrees on what it is.
Okay.
Now we are going to understand the space.
I'm in trouble.
Okay.
Delta squared as a name for a small
artist based and miserable formed or the
differences. Now we are going to
apply this to the following problem.
I'm going to give you a feeling for what
space I'm in trouble when applied to
the study of a single particle.
So previously delta x and Delta t but
separation between two random unrelated
events are arbitrary events.
But now I want you to consider the
following event you had as a particle in
space time and it moves there.
This is better. This the beginning.
That's the way I did this at the end.
So now I want delta x to be
distance.
Okay?
Logical travels
and I want Delta t to be the
time in which it did this.
Okay,
so these are two events in the life
of a particle to events laying on the
trajectory of a product
in the [inaudible] plain.
You draw a line is a trajectory because
at every time that it's an accident that
described particle motion and this is
the delta x and this is the Delta t.
Let's look at the space time
interval between the two events.
Delta s square will be c Delta
t squared minus delta x squared,
but we are going to
rewrite this as follows,
uh,
equals Mc Delta t squared times one minus
v Square Overseas Square.
That v is delta x over Delta t
because these are the two he
mentioned the life of a party,
the distance over time,
it's actually the velocity of the product.
I would always use v for the velocity of
a particle that I'm looking at and you
for the velocity difference between my
frame of reference and your frame of
reference.
So you is always the speed between frames
and v is the speed of some particular
I'm looking at. So let's take the
square root of both sides and be fine.
Delta s equal to c Delta t times square
root of one minus B squared overseas
square.
Yeah.
So the space time interval between
two events in the life of particle,
you see times the time
difference times this factor,
oh this is supposed to be an invariant.
By that I mean no matter who
calculates the space, I'm in trouble.
The person's going to get the same answer.
So let's calculate the space.
I'm in trouble as computed
by the particle itself.
What does the political thing
happened? Well, particle says,
uh,
in other words you're with the particle.
So in your frame of reference
for the particle now.
Okay.
The time difference
between the two events,
let me call it some Delta
Tau and the space difference.
What's the space difference
between the two events? Yup. Yeah,
zero because as far as the
particles concerned, I'm still here.
So if I'm moving from my vantage,
my x coordinates,
wherever they chose to put it in the
beginning and that's where it'll follow.
So the two events particle cited here
in particle cited there have different x
coordinates for a person to
whom the particles moving.
But if your co moving with the
particle then you are like,
you are x coordinate as seen by you.
Does not change.
Therefore delta x is zero.
Therefore the space time interval
will be simply see times Delta Tau,
but Tau is the time measured by
a clock going with the party.
So Delta Tau
is the time in particles frame
other words.
If the particle had its own clock,
that's the time it will say has
elapsed between the two points than its
trajectory. So it's not so
hard to understand. So I
am the product line moving.
I'm looking at my watch and I'm saying
with time will pass for me, right?
One second, two seconds. That's the time
according to me. If you guys see me,
you will disagree with me on how far
a mood and how much time it took.
That's your delta x and your Delta t.
But for me there's only Delta Tau.
There is no delta x for me.
So the space time interval when you
described particle behavior is essentially
the time elapsed according to the party.
So it's not hard to understand
why everybody agrees on that.
See you and I don't have to agree on
how much time elapsed between when the
particle was here and when it was there.
But if we ask how much time
elapsed according to the particle,
we're all asking the same question.
That's where we all get the same answer.
So the spacetime interval is called the
proper time. Proper time is another name.
Well at the time as measured by
a clock caddied with the party.
So let's write it this way.
The space time interval is really see
times Delta Tau and Delta Tau is also an
invariant.
Namely everyone agrees on Delta Tau.
And what's the relation
between Delta t and Delta Tau?
Delta t is the time
according to any old person.
And Delta Tau is the time according
to the clock. Then you saw that, uh,
the space time interval.
See Delta Tau.
Okay,
what's equal to
so delta t famous squared
or the one minus B squared,
c squared. So I'm, we are going to,
I'm starting to see cancels on
both sides. This, the relations.
So I will be using the fact
that ditto over Dt is equal.
The square root of one minus B squared.
C squared,
r d t over detail is one over square
root of one minus B squared equals c
squared.
In other words,
the time elapse between two events in
the life of a particle as seen by an
observer for whom it has a velocity
compared to as seen by a clock moving with
the particle.
That ratio is given by this
as the particle speeds up.
Let's see if it makes sense.
As we approached to see this
number of brought to zero,
that means you can say it took aquatic
has been traveling for 30 hours,
but with this number almost vanishing,
the particle books have been
traveling for a very short time.
That's the way it is.
The particular always think it took less
time to go from here to there compared
to any other observer because the clock
runs fastest in his own restaurant.
Okay, no, this is the new video, but I'm
going to use to develop the next step.
The next step is the following.
You Newtonian mechanics particles
had a position x and maybe y and Z,
but let me just say x. Let me take
one more. If that accident it had y
and these were varying with time,
then I formed a vector r
because I f times x times y
and the vector is mathematically defined
as an entity with two components so
that when you rotate the axes,
the component's going to experiment
with frame which are related to x and y.
But the cost leaders and scientists
that defined to be a vector.
Oh, if I went to you and said, okay,
that's one vector, the position vector,
can you point to me another vector?
Anybody?
No other vectors in Newtonian mechanics.
Yes sir.
You don't have any other vectors
in the good old mechanics days.
So the only vector
you've seen his position,
we lost the
very good, yeah, that's right.
So you're right to do that.
You got to use certainly know the
answers so you shouldn't hesitate.
So how do you get to
velocity from position?
You take the data with this,
you've got to ask yourself,
why does the act of taking [inaudible]
off a vector of produce and other vector
and what's the date of it to you changed
the guy by some Delta and you divide by
the time.
Well changing the is obviously vector
because difference of two vectors,
a vector dividing by time. It's like
multiplying by the reciprocal of the time.
It's like multiplying by number and
I've told you multiplying a vector by a
number also gives you a vector
maybe longer or shorter. Therefore,
Delta r is a vector because it's the
difference of our later minus are now
dividing by Delta.
T is the same as multiplying by 10,000
or a hundred thousand or a million.
It doesn't matter.
That's also a vector and the limit
is also a vector that fourth.
Then you take an end of it
[inaudible] you get it back.
Okay,
and then you can, once you got this
date of it tube, it becomes addictive.
You can take second delivery to sentence.
You said you can have acceleration.
Then you can get, you can take the
acceleration multiplier mass by a mass.
No,
that is called a scaler.
The massive particle is a number
that everyone will agree on.
It does no bad action.
Yeah,
so the product of a number and the vector
is another vector and that vector of
course is the force.
So Detroit is a vectors and
multiples of vectors by scalers,
namely things that don't change when you
rotate your axes are ways to generate
vectors.
So what I wanted to do is
I want to generate more
vectors because they only four
vector I have is the position
for vector with this. This guy,
capital x
was competence.
I write for you again our x not witness
coordinator for CT and x one which is
coordinating for x and you can put
the other components if you like.
Okay.
Now take this x to be the coordinate in
space time of an object that's moving
and I want to take the date of it to
have that to get myself something.
I could call the velocity vector
in relativity but the of cannot be.
The time did have it.
You guys have to understand that if
I take these things of course, uh,
in spacetime,
the particles moving,
I can certainly tell you where
it is at one time in bed.
It is a little later and
I can take time to it too,
but the time that have active of a
vector in four dimensions is not a vector
because time is like any other component.
Now it's like taking the white date of it,
the Webex,
that doesn't give you a vector.
You've got to take a debt of it to the
Spec to somebody that does not transform.
That is not changed from
one observer to the other.
So you have any idea
where I'm going with this?
Yes.
Pardon me?
Do you like the space?
Yes.
Are you can take data to with respect to
the time as measured by the clock with
the moving with the polycom.
So you can take the Tau Delta with two,
in other words, let the particle
move some more Moen, Delta x,
namely Delta x, Delta x one x two, etc.
That difference will also plans from
like a vector. We have seen many,
many times differences in support in a
transform like electric divided by this
guy,
oh,
which is the time according to
a clock moving with the party.
Everybody agrees on that because
we're not asking how much time elapsed
according to you are according to me.
We are going to quarrel
about that indefinitely.
We are asking how much time passed
according the particle itself.
Then no matter who computers at a time,
you will get the same answer and
that's what he wanted divided by.
Yeah,
so I'm going to form a new
quantity called velocity,
which is the dead of it to off.
This is to toe.
Then I'm going to use the
chain rule and write it as Dex,
Dt Times Dt.
Ditto.
That becomes Stan one over
one minus V squared overseas,
Square Times d x,
not the t,
the x one d t d x Two d, t, et cetera.
Okay,
so you find the rate of change as measured
by a clock moving with the particle
and that has the virtue that
watch you get out of this process.
We'll also be afforded vector.
By that,
I mean it's four components will
transform any go to moving frame.
Just like the four components of X.
Yeah.
You remember when you took x and y and
they rotated the axes experiments excos
scientists, why sign and
so on. If you take time.
Bit of it is we would find the [inaudible]
or the velocity in the rotated frame
will be the later the x and y in the old
frame by the same core science in the
same signs.
Because the act of taking derivatives,
that doesn't change the
way the object transforms.
So this is my new four vector.
In fact,
let me put the third guy
to a dx three over DT.
Yeah.
So what I did was I took the towel
data to for which we don't have good
intuition and ordered in
terms of a tea date of it too,
which we have a good intuition because
no matter how much I understand tells you
about space and time,
we think of time as different from space.
So we think in terms of time derivatives,
but to form a four dimensional vector.
It's not enough to do
that is what I'm saying.
Everybody turned that is divided by this
because that's the way of Rewriting d
by d towers.
DVDT times this factor.
Yeah,
so now I am ready to define
what I'm going to call momentum
in relativity.
It's going to be called the Ford momentum.
Everything is the for something.
The four vector port position.
This is called the four velocity.
Okay.
No, I'm going to define
something called the forward.
The forward momentum is going to be the
mass of a particle when it's sitting at
rest multiplied by this velocity.
So what does it going to be?
Let me write it out.
What does the x not over Dt. You
guys remember x Nordic. We'll set,
sorry,
x not with CT and x. Not
over. DT will be equal to c.
You're right, if that's what you
were saying. I agree with you. Yes.
So this is a vector,
m zero c all in one minus
v squared over c squared.
Then the other guy,
other components,
let me write simply as m zero times the
family at velocity times one minus B
squared over c square.
If you want it to keep the x,
Y and z velocities,
you can keep them as a vector or if he
just wanted to live in two dimensions,
one space in one time,
drop the arrow.
So we have manufactured now a new beast.
It's got four components.
What is it?
I modeled it after the old momentum.
I took the mass and multiply it by what
it's going to pass forward velocity in
my new world and I got this
creature with four parts.
You've got to understand
what the four parts mean.
It's got a part that looks
like an ordinary vector.
Yeah,
and it's got a part that
is no vectors in it.
Completely in analogy with the fact that
x had a park that looked like a vector
aimed at three spacial components and
apart that in the old days was called a
scaler because it didn't transport.
But of course in the new
world everything got mixed up.
We got to know who this is and
we have to know who this is.
So I want to show you what they are.
So he had is my new for vector m zero c
over one minus B squared or c square and
m zero let me drop the other
components except yesterday.
Aesthetics.
Let me not worry about that now.
Yeah,
I I wrote that because I want to be
able to call it the force vector.
It's crazy to call this afforded vector,
I should call it a two vector.
Do you guys have to say about it is seen
two vectors. We have seen two vectors.
Next white plain, this is a two
back that in space time audits,
part of this big four component
object with the Ford of actor in four
dimensional space time.
So we have created something and we
are trying to understand what we have
created. So I, let me
look at this guy first.
This guy looks like m Zero
v divided by this factor.
I don't know what it stands for,
but I say,
well relativistic physics should
reduce the Newtonian physics.
When I look at slowly moving optics,
because we know Newton was perfectly right
when he studied slowly moving optics.
If I go to a slowly moving up there,
so we oversee becomes negligible,
I dropped that and that becomes MV.
I know that the whole momentum,
so this guy is just the all
momentum properly corrected
for relativistic theory.
So this quantity here deserves
to be called momentum. Little P,
you can put an Arrow on it if you want
to keep the three components that don't
put an arrow.
Okay,
so that's off that four vector.
The three components are just momentum,
but not defined that the old way.
It's not am not be [inaudible]
m not divided by this.
So the moment that the particle
is very interesting in relativity,
even though nothing can
go faster than light,
that doesn't mean the momentum has
an upper limit m zero times. See,
because the momentum is not mass times
velocity mass divided by this crazy
factor.
So as you approach the speed of light,
as we approached to see the
denominator is very close to zero,
this number can become as big as you like.
So we had people building
bigger and bigger accelerators.
If you ask them how fast
is your particle moving?
But everybody in Fermi lab in cern,
it's all close to the velocity
of light is 99.9999 other person,
a few more nines. Nothing is
impressive and you look at velocity,
but when you look at the momentum,
it makes a big difference how much of the
one you have subtracted in the bottom.
If you only got a different than 19
decimal place where you got a huge moment.
So particles have limited velocity
in relativity but unlimited momentum.
It also means the speed up this particle
is going to take more and more force as
it picks up speed.
In other words,
you'll be pushing it like crazy.
It won't pick up speed,
but there's momentum will be going up.
You'll pick up speed,
but let's pick up in speed will be
imperceptible because in the 19th decimal
place of the oversea,
it will go from nine nine nine nine nine
nine nine for something near the end
that the last day. That will change.
But the woman will change a lot.
But I don't want to stop before looking
at this guy so we don't know who this is.
So we take this thing.
This is the zero component of p just
like I called it x, not in the old days,
I'm going to call it peanut.
Peanut was m zero c divided by
one minus B squared overseas.
So I don't know what to make
of this guy either. [inaudible]
t equal to zero.
I get m zero see that looked like the
mass of a particle but I have no idea.
Okay, so it's the mass
of particles. See here.
Then I put B equals zero in the bottom
because the top had a v and not the
something was leftover that looked like
something familiar. Namely momentum here.
If I take the equal to zero too quickly,
what's leftover is nothing reminiscent
of anything in Newtonian mechanics.
So you want to go in what's called
the next audit and we oversee,
you don't want to totally ignore it.
You want to keep the first non zero term.
So we write it as m zero c times one
minus via screwed overseas square to the
power.
Minus one half.
I've just written it with the thing
upstairs for the minus one half is the
exponent. Then I didn't mind you.
The good old Formula One plus extra.
The end is one plus
annex, plus dot, dot, dot.
If x is very small,
so if you use that,
you get m zero c times one
plus B squared or what?
Boosie square plus higher powers
of B squared overseas square.
So what are these terms coming out?
Well, there's the first time for a bit.
I have absolutely no intuition.
The second term,
it looks like one half
MV squared divided by c.
So the for the first time
I see something familiar.
I see the good old Kennedy energy,
but not quite because
have this number see here.
So I decided maybe I
shouldn't look at peanut,
but I should look like look at c times
p not maybe that looks something more
familiar that looked like an Nazi
square plus one half Mv Square.
That's more than what trends depending
on higher ed and higher ed powers to be
squid overseas.
Okay.
But now we know who this guy is.
This is what we used to call the
kinetic energy of a particle.
By virtue of his motion.
As the particle picks up speed,
the Kennedy going to d itself receives
more corrections because the other terms
with more and more powers.
So we oversee or not negligible,
you got to put them back in basically
up to compute this object. Exactly.
But a low velocity is,
this is the main term.
So this is what led Einstein and mainly
him to realize that this quantity is
talking about the energy of an object.
Okay.
This is certainly energy recognize
I can put it to good use, right?
You run windmills and so on.
With kinetic energy are a hydro electric
power is from churning kinetic energy
or water into work. So you figure
this is also part of the energy.
So the first conclusion of my insane
was even a particle that is not moving
seems to have an energy and
that's called the rest energy.
If the particle is moving,
then go back to the
derivation and you can find,
see at times peanut is m
Nazi squared over this thing.
This is the full expression for
the energy of a moving party,
not the approximate one. If you keep
the whole thing, this is what you get.
So this has been a particle moves.
It's got an energy that looks like
some velocity dependent defendant,
mass times c square. And when the party
glisses rested, it's got that energy.
And that's the origin of the big formula,
relating energy and mass.
So it leaves open the possibility that
even a particular at you think Vienna
particulates at rest you
have squeezed everything.
You couldn't get out of the party.
Like what more can I do for you?
You give it all it's garden and stock.
But I caught him Einstein,
that is a lot of fun left.
You can do something more if
there's a way to destroy this.
So in his theater, he doesn't
tell you how you should do that,
but it did point out that if you can get
rid of the mass because it was energy,
some other form of energy
mistake its place by the law
of conservation of energy.
So that's how we all the nuclear
reactions work and nuclear reactions. Uh,
you can take two parts, like two
hydrogen atoms, hydrogen nuclei.
You can fuse them into helium and you
will find the helium's mass is less than
the mass of the two parts. So that is
some energy missing, some mass missing.
That means some energies missing.
That's the energy released in fusion.
Or you can take uranium nucleus and give
it a tap and break it up into Barium
and Krypton and some nutrients and you
will find the fragments together and have
a mass less than the parent.
And the missing mass times c squared is
the energy of the reaction that comes
out in the kinetic energy of
the fast moving particles.
So Einstein,
this wrongly called the father of the
bomb because this is as far as you went,
didn't specify how they
extract energy from mass,
but showed very clearly that rest energy
that a particular address seems to have
a term that should be called energy
because this guy certainly is. Yes.
Uh,
we'll be three over eight m zero B,
the for over c to the fourth. Uh, I
don't carry more terms in my head,
but I can crank them out needle,
they are more corrections to
kinetic energy. In other words,
why is this an important concept?
If two particles collide,
we believe energy is conserved.
So you want to add the energy
before and competitive energy after.
If you want them to perfectly match.
If you stopped here,
your bookkeeping will not work
before will not equal after.
You've got to keep all this infinite
number of terms to get it exactly right.
But if you're satisfied to one
part in a million or something,
maybe that's as many terms as are needed.
And at very low velocities,
you don't even need that because this
is never changing in a coalition.
Every particle as restaurants,
this is what we balanced when we collided.
Remember we call it a blocks and
we balanced the kinetic energy.
Actually that energy is there in
every block, but it's not changing.
It's canceling out in
the before and after.
So unless the two blogs
annihilated and disappeared,
then you really have
something interesting. But
you don't have that in, uh,
the Newtonian physics.
Okay.
So I should tell you that I've
given you guys a two more problems.
One of which is optional.
You don't have to do that,
but it's a very interesting problem and
I want you to think about it because
it's a problem whether there's a two
rockets headed towards each other,
both have the same lengths. They one
meter and this guy thinks he is at rest.
The second rocket is
zooming past him like this.
When the tail of this rocket
pass to the tip of this,
he sends out a little torpedo aimed at
this one. Clearly it doesn't do any harm,
but looking at it from the point of
view of this person, this person says,
well I am a big rocket.
I'm moving like this.
And then when my tail met
the tip of this rocket ice,
he sent out an explosive,
which are certainly hit me down here.
So the question is,
does this upper rocket get attack?
Does it get hit by the lower one or not?
From one point of view,
you miss the other point of view when
you expand this one in shrink. This one.
You definitely got to it. So
you've got to ask. I mean,
do you get hit or don't get it? You
cannot have two answers to one question.
So I've given the problem,
we've given you a lot of hymns,
and I think even though it's optional,
if you do that problem,
you've got nothing to fear.
Okay?
We'll give you a good practice and how
to think clearly about any number of
these problems. And I've given you
enough hints on how to do that.